Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhassa
Homage to the Buddha, the Blessed, Noble and Fully Self-Enlightened One.
So, I want to just make one more talk devoted to Dependent Regeneration and it's really looking at another model.
So, if I go through the model, then you'll see that it offers a slightly different perspective.
So remember that we begin with this avijja, ignorance, right?
So we start from the platform of not knowing, but this not knowing produces a certain delusion.
So a delusion is the wrong way of looking at something.
And because of that, we've created in the past these sankharas.
So sankharas are basically all our habits.
We'll put it just down to that.
But the important thing is that they've been produced by an act of will.
In other words, we produce them.
We don't particularly produce what we see, it's just natural to the body, it's natural to the sense base.
But what you do with what you see is within your power.
And these two things, the fundamental not knowing, the delusion and the habits are running concurrent beneath every moment.
and then within every moment you've got to have this basic trilogy so the first one is the potential of cognition which is the primary act of knowing and this doesn't happen unless you've got a body and mind so the two lean against each other
and because there's a body and mind you've got your six sense bases so there's your basic human being and it's through that that you make contact with the world so that's your first active moment right contact and there has to be an object there has to be a sense base and there has to be that act of cognition from there you've got your from that you've got your basic sensations and then we
Divide the world into what we like what we don't like and there's an area of neutrality But if you look at that more closely it always shades off into liking not liking And that's the we might call the basic duality of the world, but that's not suffering now this it's at the next point that these sankaras these Volitional conditionings begin to rise in the form of desires and that's your tanha remember that
There's another word in Pali, chanda, which means a good desire, such as desire to meditate.
But tanha is a word specific to those desires which arise out of delusion.
And out of that, the next moment is that moment of identity, self.
And that's the point actually where you start suffering.
The point where you identify with what it is you want.
and as soon as you've done that it's almost impossible to stop the energy going into that process which is going to make it come out of a potential of a desire into an actual some form of action and that's your becoming, that's your karma and then as soon as you act
There has to be a beginning of the action, the middle section, and the end of it.
So that's your birth, aging and death.
Now, that's your fundamental dependent origination rolling on every so often.
Not all the time, remember.
It's only when, really, it's activated through this desire.
So it obviously doesn't happen when you're asleep.
It doesn't happen in neutral actions either.
But that doesn't mean to say that the fundamental delusion isn't there.
That's running constantly underneath every moment of our lives.
Now, in the diagram here, you see, all this produces suffering.
And the Buddha says, dukkha, that's the dukkha, yeah?
And the Buddha says that it's because of suffering that we seek the end of suffering.
That might be pretty obvious, but...
It's because we don't want to suffer that we begin to seek the end of suffering.
So suffering itself is the cause for the end of suffering.
And the way this comes about is through three things.
First of all, this wise reflection.
The Buddha is very keen on this yoni-so-maneshi-kāra so that every so often you actually look back upon your actions and work out what we've done which is harmful to ourselves.
In a sense, that's the action of conscience.
Interestingly enough, there's no word in Pali for our word conscience.
But that's another talk.
And this wise reflection, remember, brings about a certain confidence.
And that's what we mean by this faith, this confidence.
And it's through the confidence that we begin to act in skillful ways.
And as soon as we do that, it takes away all the guilt, all the shame, all the remorse from our lives and there's a natural gladness arises.
So there's a natural peacefulness in the mind.
And with this peacefulness there comes a deeper peacefulness of a rapture.
It has also a certain calmness to it, and you'll see that some of these qualities are part of the seven factors of enlightenment.
And this produces a certain contentment, a certain happiness.
Now, it's when you've got that sort of emotional base within the mind that, of course, concentration arises naturally.
It's easy.
and remember what empowers this is the desire to want to know and even when something horrible is happening within us even when we've got a depression as soon as you turn towards an investigation towards that mode that interest immediately you can feel that
at another level or a part of it or beneath it, there is this very subtle joy.
And that joy is actually mirroring the liberation, the detachment from the mental state that we're experiencing.
So, with that concentration and with that investigation there arises the knowledge and the insight, the one moves into the other.
And this knowledge and insight, remember, is always into these three characteristics, anicca, dukkha and atma, because these are manifestations of our delusion.
And with those little insights, and let's say that there are classic insights which lead to these paths and fruits.
And as it were, they're cut-off points because you can't fall down from that.
It's like when we reach the age of six, seven, and Father Christmas can't exist anymore.
You can't go back to believing it.
It's not possible.
You've got to kid yourself.
You can't go back to that open belief that Father Christmas is going to appear from Lapland with Rudolph.
So what happens is, just like with Father Christmas, you become disenchanted with that.
You don't believe in it anymore.
And that's your disenchantment.
And that's a really beautiful word for it because we tend to be enchanted by the world, bewitched by the world.
And it's this knowledge, this understanding which undermines that bewitchment, that enchantment.
Now, these moments of bewitchment and enchantment don't have to be huge, fantastic insights.
They're just little understandings that keep coming to us all the time.
And what's happening is there's a slow movement in consciousness, a slow movement in the way we're seeing the world.
And this begins to accumulate, this begins to grow.
And it manifests in the way we feel about things, the way we respond to things rather than react.
It manifests in the heart as compassion, love, sympathetic joy.
These are all qualities that arise because we're undermining that fundamental delusion which is causing this root selfishness where we can only see the world from the way that we see it and for our own benefit.
And as soon as that disenchantment comes, all the emotions around bewitchment disappear.
And that's your dispassion.
That's where the heart's beginning to really cleanse itself.
And it's at these little moments that we experience these liberations.
And that liberation is the quality of freedom that the Buddha talks about, which is the essential feel of Nibbāna.
So we get little insights like that, you see.
Nibbāna itself is a technical word.
It refers to the final end.
it's phrased as parson fruits and nibbana but that doesn't mean to say that we can't get a little inkling as to what it is to be liberated from these desires and all that takes us to what's known as the destruction of the outflows the asawa which will be my talk next week my little ten minute effort next week so
you've got this wheel of dependent origination it's constantly turning and then slowly there's an awakening of hey I'm suffering so as soon as that recognition of hey I'm suffering comes up then there's the desire to escape it and it's through this reflection it's through faith it's through good action that the faith begins to arise that in fact the path that we're on is actually leading out of it
this leads to a natural gladness which leads to a deeper state of rapture which is that interest which is wanting to know how to get out of this but that must be matched with calmness remember with calmness
and then there comes this sort of general happiness with things and it's within that atmosphere that the concentration easily grows and with it this investigation and it's in the investigation that these knowledges and insights arise
And as soon as we see something, we become disenchanted.
For instance, it's like when you overeat, and then afterwards you feel bloated, you feel heavy with it, and you have a little reflection.
You say, well, this is caused by overeating.
So the next time I see food, I'll go a bit more gently on it.
There's all these little gross examples, but as you become disenchanted,
more and more subtle within the way you observe your own psychology you see every time there's an indulgence there's always an aftermath of dissatisfaction and it's really beginning to feel the dissatisfaction which leads you to the end of it so long as when the dissatisfaction comes up you keep going back to another pleasurable state to as it were hide it from ourselves then we're not actually seeing the suffering
and so unwittingly we keep pounding this, we keep pounding the beat round and round, it's dependent origination and it's really catching the aftermath, the effects of indulgence which makes us want to stop indulging so that's part of your knowledge and insight that brings about the disenchantment with the world as a place we can seek happiness, that's all it's saying
Which, remember, is not a denial of the pleasures and joys of life.
It's that wrong relationship of thinking that this is true happiness.
And that's what leads us to this lovely place where, you know, we're enjoying things, but there's that dispassion, right?
And remember, the English word passion is quite lovely because it comes from the Latin to mean, I suffer, right?
And that's the liberation.
That's the feeling of liberation.
And slowly through this, we're undermining these āsa words, which I'll talk about next week, these outflows.
And that's looking at depend origination as a joyful process, or at least the process out of which we can find our liberation.
So I can only hope that my words have been of some assistance and that you will struggle against the old habits
and release yourself from the pain of suffering sooner rather than later.